if you are a responsible citizen of the
internet then surely you have heard of
one Nicolas Cage I said put the bunny
back in the box the actor is one of the
best of his generation an Academy Award
winner who makes a great film every few
years but in between he takes pretty
much any gig offered to him and then he
commits goddamnit which results in this
the television should get its own
Nicholas Condon and in the grand
tradition of TV he should sort of feel
like a department store knockoff of the
man
fortunately we TV fans have just that
and we've had him for years now his name
Dylan McDermott he might have been Emmy
nominated for his work on the practice
but his true strength its shouting about
things I needed you and you got a dog it
was me you should've been curling up
with that knot it's entirely possible
McDermott himself didn't know he was TVs
Nicolas Cage but as with so many things
gleeko creator Ryan Murphy looked deep
into McDermott's soul and saw a raving
lunatic just waiting to get out he made
McDermott the male lead of the first
season of American Horror Story and a
legend was born
she said twins and only one of them is
mine the sad fact is is that I'm
shooting blanks
can ask my ex-wife we try for five years
all it takes is one good swimmer
throughout that season McDermott gave
the pitch of utter defeated aunts to so
many terrible lines that became possible
to watch the show entirely to see what
he would say next you destroyed
everything even better it was never
entirely possible to tell if McDermott
was in on the joke or not which made his
performance seem all the more bizarre he
returned for an arc in season 2 in which
he played the main characters murderous
offspring sadly it was a bit of a
letdown
he went from Horror Story to CBS's
hostages but he brought with him a
strong sense that what TV needed was
frowny faces and random words being
whispered he then until the President of
the United States Ellen otherwise we
will kill your family now he's on CBS's
new stalker the show is awful and it
tries too hard to make him serious but
there are flickers here and there
what new horizons of insanity will dylan
mcdermott open up for us only time will
tell
could you put the vine back in the box